but this headline really has me hyped
for my video for this evening people are
really confused out here a lot of people
are upset not happy and they don't
realize one of the reasons that is is
they themselves are not nice enough you
want to be [__] happier have this
crazy ass concept maybe if you take the
offense and actually are more kind more
often bringing more love to more people
people that are close to you random
[__] strangers if you just start
going out of your [__] way to be kind
miraculously you become a happier person
too many glass half empty [__]
on the earth how about really
understanding how this game's actually
played make this moment the second you
deploy [__] kindness and happiness
they'll change your life